imagine you've been married for 10 years
and then your wife tells you that she
has had three Affairs each of them
lasted three years and the last one has
lasted five years and it's still ongoing
or maybe you discover that
okay so then you might say well what
happens then
well what happens is that everything you
thought was wrong if you're betrayed
badly enough not only are you not going
to understand your immediate past with
that person oh and by the way your
Future's also gone so that's a big
problem as is your present has become
radically more complex but it's worse
than that because if you're really
betrayed you're also going to think
who am I that I could be that stupid and
then you're going to think what is a
human being that they can be that
corrupt you ended up establishing a
relationship with someone who was really
not good for you
and that might mean well they just it
was just a bad personality match or it
might mean they really weren't good for
you because you know you could get
pretty unlucky and you can get tangled
up with someone who's very deceitful and
very malevolent and who could care less
about you or maybe who even wants to
hurt you and then you can establish a
trusting relationship with them or at
least you trust them and then one day
you know you find out that they are not
who they said they were or even more
importantly they are not who you thought
they were it's like a you don't know
that person B they're not communicating
with you nor are you with them maybe
they're just subordinating themselves to
you or you to them and you're not
growing you want someone who can
a real relationship is a wrestling match
it's a grappling it's a grappling
phenomena that you both emerge
transformed from and that's what people
want they don't want to push over not
not unless there's something wrong with
them and a narcissistic person who never
wants to be challenged will want a
partner who does nothing but deliver
exactly what they're told to deliver but
they will mistreat them beyond belief
what is the optimal relationship look
like in terms of positive and negative
emotion you might say well Utopia
nothing but positive interactions it's
like no
imagine you get people to code
the interactions they have with their
partner during the day you know you
sample it you say was that interaction
positive or negative and then what
you're trying to do is predict the
longevity of the relationship okay so
here's the data
if it falls under five positive
interactions to one negative interaction
the relationship doesn't continue fair
enough too much negative that's easy to
understand if it exceeds 11 positive to
one negative the relationship doesn't
last why
no challenge
right what do you want from your partner
Bliss no no no you don't you have to pay
attention to your own
uncomfortable negative emotions in order
to manage that and not and not pretend
that everything's all right or that
you're nicer than you are or that you're
less jealous than you are or or or less
blind or whenever a hiccup occurs in the
relationship maybe you don't call it out
at each hiccup you know because you have
to have a certain amount of Silent
tolerance in any relationship to let
small infractions go but if they repeat
my rule is three times and it's the rule
that we I share with my wife if
something happens three times that is
causing emotional upset anger jealousy
disappointment resentment frustration
any of those things anything that you
don't want to experience and that you
especially don't want to experience
repeatedly then you can call it out and
and if you if you have three examples
your case is much better made than if
you just have one
you project your idealization onto the
person that you're romantically
attracted to that's the projection of an
archetype so young would say the woman
will project Anonymous onto the man the
Animus is her conceptualization of what
the ideal man is it's unconscious
because it's rooted in fantasy and the
man will be in concordance with that
projection in some areas that's those
are the areas where she likes them by
the way and will be discordant in other
areas and that's the areas where she
constantly disappoints him as the
relationship develops
so the projection is there in part to
help the person understand who it is
that they're dealing with because when
you meet someone you have to you have to
assume something about them it's the
same as projection you have to assume
something about I mean if you find them
fascinating which is what happens if you
fall in love maybe it's because they
smell good or they're symmetrical or
something you immediately assume that
well those things really matter you
immediately assume that they embody the
ideal it's an oversimplification but
oversimplification has a basis and the
basis is if it's interesting to me it
must be close to the ideal well yeah
except the person that you're going out
with attracted to do is Warped and bent
and flawed and twisted in you know 300
ways and you'll find that out soon
enough just as they will about you and
that often just blows the relationship
into pits because the person will say
well she wasn't who I thought she was
like well who said whoever said she was
who you thought she was it's like where
did you get the misapprehension that she
was going to be who you thought she was
so there's a big problem here my wife
had an affair question mark what's going
on
but then they provide an answer
I still love her when when a bomb like
that goes off in the midst of your life
everything is up for grabs
and so to immediately say I still love
her it's like yeah maybe and maybe not
and if that's all you feel well then
that in itself is definitely a problem
and also might be a key to why it
happened to begin with because you
appear to be the sort of person who can
be stomped on pretty damn hard and not
object I think modern women don't really
understand about men they don't
understand that
at least to the degree that males are
uncorrupted and not better because of
being rejected they're doing everything
they can to kneel before the Eternal
image of the feminine
and try to make themselves Worthy
that's the chivalry story right that's
what you should encourage in your
partner a lot very large number of my
clinical clients but also young men I've
talked to in general
are absolutely terrified of women
because they're terrified of being
rejected and the terror exists in
precise proportion to the retraction to
the woman
which is a horrible paradoxical
situation to be in it's often why men
make such fools of themselves in front
of women that they're attracted to it's
because first of all they don't see the
woman that they're attracted to because
what the hell do they know about her
they don't see her as an individual they
see her as the manifestation of a
judgmental ideal
and then it's only in establishing the
relationship with the actual woman that
they can start differentiating between
the judgmental ideal and and the actual
individual woman and that also requires
a sacrifice and the sacrifice is
you never can have an ideal woman
so to have a relationship with any woman
you have to sacrifice the relationship
with the ideal woman and you have to see
the individual woman
and separate her from the ideal and
that's the same thing that happens to
the hero in Sleeping Beauty right he
sees the evil queen who actually turns
into the dragon of chaos and it's not
until he can he can defeat her that he
can establish a relationship with the
actual princess one of my clients who
ran this men's group which was quite
interesting one of the things they had
the initiates
do which was very intelligent was to go
out and ask 50 women in one day for
their phone numbers
why politely properly you know it wasn't
it wasn't it was a game but it wasn't a
stupid game and the idea was get over
your fear of rejection and how do you do
that by encountering it continually and
continually and continually so that
you're no longer Paralyzed by this the
question is
well
what do you do in the garden
given that there's a snake in it and the
answer to that is something like you
become the master of snakes
and so
and that's a deep idea that's the same
idea as confronting the dragon and
getting the treasure that's the same
idea as going to the bottom of the ocean
and rescuing your father from the belly
of the whale
it's the same idea
and that's an element in the greatest of
stories and the greatest of stories is
heroic heroic story and the heroic story
is to voluntarily confront the unknown
when it manifests itself and to gather
something of value as a consequence and
to share it with the community there
isn't a story that's more emblematic of
what it means to be human than that that
that is us that's our best bet